well a teenager in Michigan says that
she had to deal with cyber bullying for
more than a year and police have
discovered it was her mother who was
allegedly behind it all authorities say
Kendra Gail licari sent her own daughter
mean harassing and hateful messages
through text and social media police say
she sent the anonymous messages to both
her daughter and her daughter's then
boyfriend when her daughter came to her
for help lacari allegedly told the
police about the harassment but tried to
make it seem like it was coming from her
daughter's peers police say there were
several hundred text messages filling
thousands of pages of Discovery lucari
who coached basketball for the local
school district was led out of jail on a
five thousand dollar Bond her charges
include stalking of a minor and using a
computer to commit a crime officials
haven't identified a motive well another
parent raising eyebrows right now is the
father of Robert crimo III police say
cremo gunned down people watching a
Fourth of July parade in a Chicago
suburb charges were filed against Robert
crimo Jr for allegedly helping his son
to get a license to legally own firearms
in Illinois you have to be older than 21
to get a firearm owner's identification
card someone younger can get one if a
guardian sponsors them cremo has
admitted to helping his son get the card
and told the Chicago news station that
he doesn't regret it seven people died
in the parade attack police say cremo
aided in the crime by helping his son
get the weapon that he used they also
say cremo was aware that his son could
be dangerous after multiple violent or
dangerous incidents cremo is charged
with seven counts of Reckless conduct
now the kareemo case is very similar to
the crumbly case out nearby Michigan
they are parents Jennifer and James
crumbly are charged with involuntary
manslaughter their son shot up a school
last year killing four students he
pleaded guilty earlier this year but the
prosecution says the crumblies knew
their son had mental health issues but
ignored that and bought him a gun right
now an appeals court set to determine if
the couple can get bail or not Brian
these are some really wild cases and I
don't have to say how controversial
there are but how much responsibility
does a parent really have legally
speaking I mean Jesse that's the million
dollar question here now first we'll
start with cremo for each of the felony
Reckless conduct charges he could face
one to three years on each of those
charges prosecutors are basically saying
he was so careless in buying his son a
gun that a reasonable person in that
situation would not have done so first
like you said as their crumbly parents
now as Primo Jr the question that is
Raising now is what red flags and how
many of them lead to a mass shooting and
what responsibility do parents have when
it comes to buying firearms for their
children now cases like this are
controversial how much blame a parent
should take but catfishing your child
and their boyfriend this is what I've
never seen before lucari is Presumed
Innocent but the facts don't look good I
get tough love but demeaning demoral
realizing and mean to text to your child
for over a year what was this woman
thinking she's looking at maybe two to
three years yeah Terry okay you don't
need to prove a motive to convict
someone of a crime but what is the
motive for stalking your own child you
know I just don't understand this except
maybe she's trying to change the child's
Behavior obviously that's not an excuse
and this is something that can easily be
proved through forensic evidence they're
going to take the computer they're going
to look at what was written and they're
going to trace it right back to the
mother and the worst part of all of this
is the fact that their relationship will
never ever be the same the daughter is
not going to trust her mother and who
knows why the daughter and the boyfriend
broke up but I am sure it had something
to do with this bullying by the mother
it makes no sense at all I think that
she probably should seek some help
psychologically because when you do
something like that to someone who
you're supposed to be protecting she
went to her mother for protection and
obviously it didn't work yeah we need
more details she is innocent until
proven guilty but I'll tell you this
much we covered a lot of Trials probably
one of the most bizarre I've heard in
quite some time